What can they do to stop it? Well,
the game, the game strategy's clear,
they've deployed it before,
right? So, um, you know,
they'll, they'll say things like,
this is welfare for politicians.
Um,
this is just corrupting free speech.
You don't believe in the first amendment
if you don't believe that, you know,
the Koch brothers are,
the sources have the right to spend
unlimited amounts of money and political
speech.
Um,
and so I think the way around that
fight is to agree free speech is the
fundamental value.
And nothing of the reforms I support would
like try to restrict people's ability
to speak. What we're talking about
is congressman raising money.
We're not talking about individual
speaking in the marketplace.
So you have a very loud voice.
Joe,
your voice is heard by millions and
nothing in our constitution should permit
the government to be able
to suppress you at all.
So long as you're within the
bounds of decency or at least, uh,
not decency because that's not
a bound boundary. This thought,
guess obeys often, but, but at
least if you're not, you know,
spreading false rumors and causing
great harm. But the point is, um,
even though this free speech
needs to be protected,
we still should be able to focus on
the influence the economy of influence
congressmen live under when they spend
30 to 70% of the time sucking up to the
lesters to fund their campaigns.
That should be a focus of regulation
without the first amendment getting in the
way because we want to Congress filled
with people who care about what their
voters want,
not what their funders want.
The framers didn't create a constitution
to replicate an aristocracy.
They were fighting and aristocracy.
They had a system where there was a house,
the House of Lords, the had to ask
the aristocracy, what do you want?
And everything could be blocked if
the aristocracy didn't like it. Well,
we've replicated that system more
efficiently in America than they had there
because we have a system where both the
House of Representatives and the Senate
is filled with people who are
obsessed with a single question,
what to my funders want?
And if they can't answer that question
in a way that supports the legislation
and they're not going to support the
legislation or if it's important for them
to block legislation,
they will block legislation.
And that's the dynamic of Washington right
now. Um, uh, Francis Fukuyama describes,
uh, our government has a
veto ocracy veto ocracy.
And what he means by that is that
there's so many places we're influenced.
Powerful influence can block the ability
of the government to do something.
Did it just can't do anything
anymore. And that's, I think,
the consequence of allowing
this corruption of money
to be so deeply woven into
our political system. Is
it possible to fix? Yeah,
it is possible effects because
you know, for, for example,
HR one plus Roca Han is bill
all perfectly constitutional.
You wouldn't have to amend
the constitution to do it.
I think that bill alone would
solve 80% of the problem.
The possibility,
the problem isn't like conceiving
of what changes have to happen.
The question is how do you build
the political movement to get there?
And what that takes is
leaders willing to say,
we have to fix this corrupted
democracy first. And,
and leaders who stopped,
like pretending that we can get like
a Christmas list of great changes in
government without fixing this
democracy for it. So, you know,
Bernie published our last month in the
Washington Post list of the 10 things
that should happen in the first
hundred days in the next democratic
administration.
10 great ideas,
not a single one of those ideas address
the corruption of our political system.
You know,
it was just,
it was just a Christmas list of all the
things that the progressives want it.
And you know, I'm a progressive,
I want some of those things.
But the point is which things were the,
you know,
things like a trillion dollar
infrastructure project, single pair,
healthcare free college, um, you know,
all the things that Bernie is pushing,
it has made so sale it and things that
I think it's great that he has made
salient.
I mean,
he's a hero and like making these
issues central to at least the debate.
But what frustrates me is that
instead of focusing our anger on the
billionaires, which he does, we need
to focus more anger on the congressman,
the politicians, which
he does not. I mean,
the guy's been in Congress
for almost 30 years now.
And so it might be natural for him not
to notice that the people around him are
the problem,
that natural thing.
Or do you think that he's possibly aware
of the consequences of stirring up that
Hornets Nest? Because you know, if
anybody has a right to complain,
when the DNC conspired to rig
the primaries against him,
he's the number one guy.
He should be screaming from the rooftops.
You're dealing with a corrupt system and
this is disgusting. And he'd done it,
didn't do that.
And he didn't do that while he'll,
Hillary Clinton was running
for president and he knew it.
He knew that he had been
screwed out of the primaries.
He knew they had conspired.
He knew it was all illegal,
and he kind of just kept his mouth shut.
Yeah. Well, I think, you know,
that was a responsibility.
I think that was a kind of,
um, um, you know,
I was a person reflecting
on the horrendous outcome
if he took Hillary Clinton
down. And so I think he
restrained himself. Um, you
know, not perfectly. I mean,
the fact is after it was clear he
was not going to be the nominee,
he still continued to talk about
the coat corruption round Hillary,
which Donald then picked up and
turned it into a weapon against her.
But I think he, he recognized, you know,
is every responsible politician does that.
You know, it's not just about him,
it's about the future of America.
So when he restrained himself and didn't
want to take the whole system down,
then, um, I get that. But
what I'm talking about now,
I'm talking about when you've got the
House of Representatives talking about
fundamental reform,
it will be the first they take up.
We at least ought to have a presidential
campaign where candidates are saying,
hell yes.
The first thing we will do is to end the
corruption that makes it impossible for
this congress to function and stop
pretending like we can get all these
wonderful things given to us by Santa
Claus without fixing this first.
You gotta do the hard work of convincing
America that there is a solution
because you know,
the reality is I think most of America
is where you started this podcast.
Most of America thinks it's deeply
corrupted and there's nothing that can be
done. They're half right. It is
deeply corrupted, but it's not true.
There's nothing that can be done.
We can do something.
And in fact I think we can solve
almost uh, you know, 80% of it.
I still think there's constitutional
changes that might be necessary.
And I've been working like how do we get
constitutional changes and talking to
people at PR, my, my podcast,
which of course has about one 1000th
of the one 1000000th of the people
listening to yours does,
but as your podcast so people
can listen to it's another way.
So season two is released today,
which is about an article five convention.
But season one was about how to think
about the 2020 election. Um, um, but,
you know, I think that, uh,
we might have to have constitutional
change and I have been supporting the
efforts to think about that.
But what we've got to do is to give people
a sense that there's something we can
do before we amend the constitution.
You know,
we did a poll and found 96% of Americans
believe it important to reduce the
influence of money in politics.
And 91% didn't think it was possible.
So that's the politics of resignation.
You know,
if you'd gone to Egypt under Mubarak
and you'd stop the average person in the
street and said, you know, what do you
think of Mubarak? They would have said,
you know, we hate Mubarak. And they say,
why aren't you doing anything about it?
And they say, because nothing
can be done. Or, you know,
African Americans in 1900 and
America, what do you think
about Jim Crow? You know,
we hate Jim Crow. Why aren't you
doing anything about it? Well,
because there's nothing
to be done about it. Well,
that's how Americans think about this
political corruption. They hate it.
They think it's deeply unjust,
inconsistent with what they
thought America was about,
but they don't do anything
about it because they don't
think there's anything to
be done about it.
And that's where leaders have a role
and what we need our leaders running for
president right down to
begin to explain to people,
here's what we could do if only
we built the power to do it.
Recognizing the most
important opposition here.
The lobbyist in Washington are going to
be an incredibly difficult group to to
defeat. But we can do
that. And if we do that,
every other issue becomes easier
to resolve in a sensible way.